There you go.
You are now live with Layer Eight Culture,
Tech Thursday.
Oh, we just got live?
Oh my gosh.
Welcome, welcome everybody.
Part of the Layer Eight Culture Tech
Thursdays.
Oh, it's running.
Where's the...
Oh, well, we're on layer A culture.
We are waiting for the man himself.
He's going to come right in.
Got a lot of notes here.
He is developing so much amazing things
using AI.
You definitely want to stay tuned.
And as I
Because we adjust.
A lot of this stuff is going to
be super, super polished.
I'm excited about it.
I'm totally excited about it.
Welcome back.
Oh, we're back.
Man, what happened?
I don't know, man.
I was just keeping the people waiting for
you right there.
That intro must have been so crazy and
insane, man.
Because I hit the go live button,
the intro started playing,
and then it crashed out.
Yeah, I don't know what happened.
Oh man, it's all good, it's all good.
Oh man.
Tonight, this is kind of an open,
I guess it's like an open build,
kind of what I'm building type of episode.
So we'll talk a little bit about...
So that's why I got my glasses on,
you know.
The sun.
We're getting real close to the sun now.
We got to wear our UV protection.
That's it.
It's getting hot out here.
It is.
And it's summertime, too.
Oh, my gosh.
Tell me about it.
It's definitely, definitely,
definitely hot.
Well, let's get into it, man.
Let's get into it.
So let me share my screen.
I'm going to jump right into it.
CLI.
So of course in layer a culture,
we talk about different levels or layers
of AI and everything at the base
foundation or the AI models.
Actually, let me, I'll share my,
I'll share what I have here.
Okay.
by the way folks uh we're getting ready
to have and solidify a date where we're
going to be doing well well the layer
eight culture team is going to be uh
at the lab over in coco um just
doing a little uh a little teaser of
all of the knowledge in this gentleman's
uh arsenal
so um yeah you definitely don't want to
miss out that uh this is just just
to tease the tease the population to
understand there's so much different
opportunities so much creativity in this
thing so i'm excited i know you will
be too so stay tuned indeed so right
here we have this is what i call
the different the five levels of ai right
so so at the foundation we have our
ai model so
if you look at OpenAI, Anthropic, Google,
Meta, Minstrel AI, they all have,
they're actually the companies that own
the AI models.
A lot of people refer to them now
as Mango.
In the tech space,
that just stands for Meta, Anthropic,
the N stands for Google, OpenAI,
I don't know what E stands for.
Anyway, it's Mango.
But, um,
Then what happens is you build on top
of those AI models.
So you have like a ChatGPT,
you got your Cloud,
which is part of Anthropic,
Gemini is part of Google, complexity,
Microsoft CodePilot is multi-model,
so it's OpenAI, Google, Anthropic,
and so on and so forth, right?
And in those models,
you do a lot of the chatting stuff
where you go into the website, you know,
ChatGPT,
You might pay for it,
but basically you're chatting with the AI
model.
That's the consumer level.
Then you have workflows.
So you do some automation.
Let's say you have some scheduling that's
done.
You have to automate through N-A-N.
We've done a lot of that with social
media content.
Go high level is big automation.
Microsoft Popile allows you to schedule.
Zapier is huge.
It's kind of an enterprise version of
N-A-N.
So that's like your workflows,
things that you're automating.
A lot of people will call that agents.
That's not necessarily an agent, per se.
It's more of just a loop or like
a repetitive workflow that you're using.
Or more like automation, really.
And then right here,
that's the level I like to build at.
That's the creator builder level.
So the tool I use is GitHub Cloud
Cloud CLI.
you that in a sec it's the same
thing as cloud code a lot of people
use cursor very similar open claw has been
very popular it's been kind of quiet
though replit it's another popular one a
lovable is another popular one is that the
one now i've seen some ads on lovable
is that the one where you can basically
talk into it and then come up with
a website is that the one
Lovable is big on making websites.
I think they also make apps on it
too.
But all these basically,
you can build apps.
So you basically could just tell it what
you want to create and it can create
it.
Wow.
With no code.
You don't even have to have a coding
experience.
It creates a code.
That's the thing.
When you're chatting with it,
it's actually developing code that you can
then run on your computer.
Are we going to be able to play
on here?
Because I got so many different ideas.
That's what we build in public, man.
Like your website,
the Real Estate Deal Lab,
that was built on GitHub, Cobalt, CLI.
Everything we build is GitHub, Cobalt,
CLI.
Okay.
And that's different than Plot, then?
Yeah, it's very similar,
but it's different than our code.
But so...
We'll get into it.
So Cloud Code is super similar to GitHub
Copilot CLI.
It does the exact same thing,
but the cool thing about GitHub Copilot is
that it's multi-model.
So remember when we talked about the
different models down here?
Right, right.
We use GitHub Copilot,
and you pay for the subscription and all
that.
You actually get access to multiple
models, so OpenAI models, Google,
Anthropic.
So you can, like, mix and, you know,
you're not stuck with just one particular
AI company.
Oh, man, what happened?
I don't know.
I was just about to take some notes.
Y'all are getting the game right now, man.
That's what this is about, man.
We build them public.
I keep telling them, man.
That's it.
Right in front of everybody.
Build it right there.
Okay.
All right.
So now this is what a coder's...
This is like a coder's dream because like
the ones...
These numbers and these slashes...
They mean something.
But to me, my eyes are exploded.
You know what I mean?
So thank God for gentlemen like you that
know how to do this.
So if you need somebody to code for
you and create this,
because you still have to tweak these in
order to make it what you truly want.
You know what I mean?
Because AI is not going to know everything
what you want.
And your prompts might not be as good.
So for a fact,
that's the fact with me.
Yeah.
So it's updated right now.
Just take a sec.
Here we go.
You know what?
You said let's build in public.
What are we building tonight?
Can we build that Mama Green Food site?
We can, actually.
She's like, I want to do stuff.
I said, all right, I got you.
We got to get your website done.
We don't do the old school way too
much.
We do it, but you don't have to.
You know what I'm saying?
I want a door knock.
Nah, I got you.
Yeah, we'll touch on that.
So here's the CLI.
Like if I put in a model and
I,
you actually can get access to all these
models here,
but I got some organizational policies
that block me from table five.
You know, it's just, yeah,
it's four different screens.
So these are, what are all these?
Are these?
Yeah.
So all these are different AI models.
So you have cloud, sonnet, four point six,
four point five,
they got the gpt models and then even
within these models like so you could
change the reasoning like extra high so
and like lower the reasoning the faster
your response is going to be from the
ai model oh that's a that's a gem
hold on take take it slow with that
you know so so the higher so repeat
that again
Yeah,
so you can actually update the reasoning.
You can do this within the ChatGPT
interface as well.
I've done that, yeah, recently.
But by default, it's at medium.
You can up it to high or extra
high or even max on my plan.
But with max,
it's going to take a little bit longer
for it to come with a response.
It's just going to reason over extra long.
And you just got to know,
if you're asking it to do something very
simple,
there's no reason for you to use max
just to be like, oh, man,
it's not the same result.
You're going to really waste a lot of
tokens,
have a lot of time waiting for that
result.
And if you notice within ChatGPT,
you could change that from high to medium,
but sometimes it automatically adjusts it
based on the demand of the server.
long like in busy times it'll actually
drop you down to medium because you could
go and manually adjust it back to high
if you want something to be aware of
um i have been on max because i've
been doing like deep research right right
so i just leave it on max and
this thing's been running for like hours
on hours and hours just going through
stuff and uh i'll talk a little bit
about what i've been researching so this
specific project that i'm working on
I'm the family historian,
and our roots are back in Jamaica.
And what we've been doing is...
We got a question.
A question.
Let's see.
Is GBT so better than FODMAP?
I would say yes.
There's two reasons.
So off the bat, when it comes to...
See, and you say Claude.
I'm thinking he means Claude Fable V.
And I would say it is better because,
first of all, Fable V is dumb expensive.
Because you're actually paying for your
token usage,
especially when you're at the API level.
In the chat interface,
you're still kind of paying for it.
But
Based on your plan,
you get a certain amount of usage.
Once you hit that limit,
they drop you back down to like, oh,
four point eight.
So for you to be able to use
Fable, like on your project,
it went through.
You do have to pay a premium with.
It's so.
Same thing kind of happens,
but it's harder to happen because the way
it uses tokens is more efficient.
You're not going to hit that max as
easy.
So I've looked at different benchmarks.
That's a good, that's a good,
that's a good point right there though.
Yeah.
So, so, so, um,
so Claude soul better because it,
it maximized the usage.
Yeah, so GPT maximizes your usage.
Claude Babel is a bit expensive.
Yeah, yeah.
And that's the cool thing about... Sorry,
I flip-flopped it, by the way.
Yeah, you're good.
I caught it.
So the good thing about being able to
use multiple models, especially like...
So if I...
Let me try to give an example.
Actually,
we'll do it live when we build your...
green foods website but the cool thing
about cli is that i can let's say
i could prompt it to build something right
and it'll build it just that on that
model with that specific um uh i want
to say level of reasoning right but i
could go into what's called a fleet mode
or use utilize sub agents where i could
say hey
I want you to go into fleet mode
to get this task done.
And what it does, it literally says, okay,
I'm going to have, like,
to get to this goal of build a
website, I'm going to actually deploy,
like, five other AI models on each task.
Oh, wow.
And based on the task,
it's going to be like...
yeah it'll automatically be like hey this
is a complex task i'm gonna give it
to a better model if this is a
quick task like oh i just need you
to do the copyright for the website like
little words and stuff i'm gonna give that
to an even lesser model and what happens
is you're even more it's even more
efficient as far as being able to utilize
utilize the tokens but then you actually
get a faster response so it's pretty it's
pretty insane man when you see an action
but i've been using that technique with
this uh research so like i was saying
my roots go back to jamaica and in
jamaica they have like a document they're
pretty good on documenting i'm not gonna
say they don't document anything but
they're pretty good at documenting births
and marriages and like baptisms things
like that so who's now which one is
good at that uh i'll say in jamaica
In Jamaica, they document, you know,
birth, baptisms, and marriage.
So they have, like, these little,
you know, they have the certificates.
And they've gotten to the point where
they're scanning these certificates in.
So there's actually,
I think it's called J-A-R-D or something
like that.
There's already a government office that
scans everything in.
It keeps records.
And they have it online.
I think the name of the website is
familysearch.org.
It's a big one.
Ancestry.com has a lot of information.
There's a bunch of different online
sources.
I've been doing the genealogy historian
thing for a couple years,
about four years now.
A lot of times you've got to go
through, you've got to search the name,
search the date.
You pull it up,
and what happens is they'll scan it,
but they'll have someone actually
transpose it.
So sometimes that person that transposes
it might get a letter off or might
get a number off, you know,
because they were writing,
they're writing cursive there.
So it's not like it's all cursive,
like really bad.
Yeah, exactly.
So like, if you're going through Maine,
like you might catch that stuff.
You might not.
Yeah.
For the most part, this is like,
if you're, if you know about genealogy,
like it's,
you take hours and hours and hours to
go through all these things.
especially when you're limited on
resources.
So I was like, man,
I want to put this stuff into an
AI model and see what it can do.
We got two questions real quick.
Sorry.
Nice.
I'll try GPT-SOL then.
I keep running out of credits on Claude.
That's definitely going to happen.
And Jane Weaver is saying,
which is easier use for research, ChatGPT,
SOL, or Claude?
Man, I used to say, Claude,
I'm sold on OpenAI.
Yeah.
So if you know, like,
the way I position it is that when
using Claude,
I feel like I'm in an Oxford University.
Like, Claude is very, like, posh, very,
like,
it's going to give me a whole paper
I didn't even ask for.
And I got to read through it.
I got to understand the lingo.
Man, it's like I'm reading, you know,
encyclopedia and that's cool for like
certain things like that was cool research
but now that i'm and then like open
ai always refer to that as like streets
i'm like man open ai is always for
the streets like i ask the question and
it just gives it to me in plain
english right it cuts out all the extra
jargon just gives me my answer it gives
me what i want and i can move
on so i've always been a fan of
um
OpenAI.
And then even with ChatGPT,
a lot of people don't realize, like,
it's a really good deal.
You pay the twenty dollars a month.
It's so good.
It is so good.
You get premium image generation.
Like,
the image generation that GPT can do is
insane.
You can do a lot with that.
So you get premium image generation.
You still get the great chat capabilities.
And even now,
they're doing a codex thing where you can
pretty much...
kind of build lightweight apps within
ChatGPT.
And then just like Delcris said here,
like, your credits go a long way.
Can we show them a little bit of
the screen, like, while you're talking?
Let's go through the little options
that... Yeah.
You know,
I might not even remember that one.
Yeah,
so that's a new thing that they started.
I haven't even touched it yet,
to be honest.
But let me go through.
We'll do a live and see how it
looks.
Let's see.
Well, we have Crystal.
I guess she's coming on the chat.
Crystal,
you got to turn your video on if
you want to come to the chat.
If you want to come on stage.
Let's see.
All right,
let me go back to my web browser,
and we'll go to ChatGPT.
So let me zoom out.
All right, so...
sidebar see i didn't even hit it so
there's supposed to be oh here it is
work guys this is the first time i'm
doing this like this is so this is
so live right now so i love it
so here's the thing i was talking about
so i just want to let you know
yours is way different than mine because
you gotta you gotta organize in a certain
kind of way this thing's a mess like
the only thing i have organized is your
your folder bro that's everything else is
like i've been talking about this for
weeks wanting to go through and like
organize my stuff because it does actually
help if you have the uh the project
folders it does um keep good context but
man that's me it's like wow so let's
see
got some stuff right here for actually
your deal lab here instagram comments
that's kind of crazy i'm not gonna mess
with that though um let's do something
really lightweight oh here's the thing i
was gonna talk about so you guys should
adjust the reasoning so it actually break
breaks it down real good for you right
here so the light reasoning is faster
responses the medium
that shot if you notice when i opened
it up it didn't give me by default
light which i've never seen before so that
tells me that they're probably under like
heavy usage but they especially it being
evening time a lot of people are online
doing stuff so let me just do like
a quick uh build a layer a culture
Something real simple.
I want to see if it actually builds
the app.
Okay, yep.
So it understands I want a web-based
calculator.
And this is just straight off of ChatGPT?
No one?
Okay.
Yeah, so if you see,
when I got into ChatGPT,
there's a tab at the top that said
Chat.
I flipped that over to work.
Okay.
Oh,
so it's flipped it over to work and
that's the way he was able to get
that.
So, yeah.
Wow.
And you could download the app from right
there and set it up.
I don't know, to be honest,
this is my first time I'm trying to,
I've seen demos.
That'd be dope.
That's something new.
You know, honestly,
I'm thinking like there was a guy that
made a lot of the gym equipment, right?
And in order to sell the gym equipment,
he had it was a nineteen year old
young bodybuilder.
He wanted to be a bodybuilder.
They they put him in a warehouse or
whatever.
And they said, hey,
this is what you're going to have to
do.
I feel like I need that type of
like, hey,
just stay in the in this lab all
day for the next forty days.
And let's see what I mean.
This this is so much game right here.
This is this is amazing.
See, that's what we did with FileFlow,
man, the twenty-four hour stream.
We gotta do that again.
We gotta do this twenty-four hour stream
again.
Like, literally, just lock in.
Yeah, that would be dope.
Because with FileFlow, man, we literally,
I didn't even use cloud code before.
I literally started the stream,
we installed it,
and we just started building stuff.
Dang, that's... Yeah, twenty-four hours.
That's so good.
Yeah, we got to set that up, Nathaniel,
for sure.
Yeah, let's do it.
You know, I got grown kids, so,
you know, at the end of the day,
I'm available, okay?
But I know you're going to be falling
asleep, though, man.
Hey, listen, I'm holding it together.
You said you were about to build
something.
You know, I'm a builder.
I like to build.
Indeed, indeed.
I'm going to work it out.
Don't worry.
If I get up,
That means I'm going to go get a,
get a, get a glass of water.
All right.
Right here until we, yeah, we, we here.
There you go.
We are here.
Yeah.
You know, you know, uh,
my bedtime is already, you know,
it's already there.
It's already passed.
Yeah.
It's already passed there.
I got to run to my house after
this.
Yes.
I,
so this is why I guess why I
had me on light mode.
Cause this is taking forever to respond.
And I'm, I'm like borderline.
borderline i do want to upgrade to the
the next tier i feel like i use
chat gpt so much i might as well
and you are supposed to get like a
faster response when you upgrade to that
next tier so i got that on my
list of things to do i think i'm
gonna pull the trigger and do it but
uh real quick while we're we'll have that
wording on the side but let's start a
new chat so
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Whoa, wait.
He said, let's work on the side.
Yeah, you can.
Come on.
You got multiple chats going.
You know that, right?
Bro, I haven't done that.
I haven't.
Yeah.
You don't got to sit here and wait
and stare at it.
No, no.
You started a new chat.
And then what happens is when it's done,
you'll go down here and actually look like
a blue bubble.
Like, hey, this is ready for you.
I haven't done that.
See, that's what I'm saying.
I need to be locked in, bro.
I need to be just like...
That'd be ambidextrous, man.
That's right.
How many chats can you have before we
go on?
How many chats can you have going at
the same time at any given moment?
Say, for instance,
I want to make some content,
but I also want to do some research
and I want to create an app and
I want to kind of like how the...
What was that show?
Jarvis.
How can I make this chat GPT my
Jarvis?
Everybody wants to do that.
It's just from the movie.
Welcome, Nathaniel.
It makes sense, but is it practical?
I don't know.
Anyway, that's for another discussion.
I don't think it actually limits you.
Let's see.
I'm surprised I didn't get an AI response.
That's weird.
Tell me when I'm in Google.
And thank you all for jumping in and
asking your questions.
We definitely love that.
Like, like,
like what we're doing right now,
we're really building on site.
So definitely chime in what you want to
see.
You know what I mean?
We could also have it on the next
episode.
So layer eight culture is a movement
building on site.
We will build it.
So, yeah.
So it looks like you can have unlimited
number of chat sessions.
Oh,
Story history,
open as many simultaneous browser tabs as
your device can handle.
Now,
you might get an error or a message
saying there's too many requests, I guess.
But there's no limit.
But you don't know unless you just try
it out.
Exactly.
And I think for me,
I probably had maybe three.
See how it popped up right here?
Calculator features,
and then you got the little bubble.
Right, right, right.
What's going on?
Oh, snap.
Let's see.
Great choice, blah, blah, blah.
Allow for this chat.
I guess this is another thing, too,
because we have to have,
especially as entrepreneurs,
that are not really familiar and are still
learning this AI space, we have to say,
OK, what can be created?
Because a lot of times I'd be like,
oh, hey, let me call this guy.
Let me call this girl.
Let me look for somebody to do this.
But like,
ninety-eight percent of what I need might
be done right here,
and then all of a sudden,
I can go with a full polished product
to meet the source, right?
So, I mean, this is game changer.
This is a Layer A culture AI value
calculator that we just built out.
Can we throw that in the chat so
people could get a link of it?
So right now,
so what happens is when it builds,
it's actually building on the local
computer.
We call that the local host.
I would have to send this out to
my Azure environment.
that's in the cloud,
and then I would actually have a URL
that I could share with everyone.
Okay, that's dope.
This is like,
this is where it starts as far as
like,
I see this is actually an active thing.
So you could put, man,
the writing is really small on this.
So that's what I was saying earlier.
You saw me with my face.
I'm just like, yeah,
let me zoom in here.
Dang, the zoom is like weird.
All right.
So let me do this.
and this is that that's a little bit
better yeah so you can look at the
workflow type let's say we're doing some
type of reporting data entry the number of
people involved so let's like let's say
you have a small team of you know
six people the hours per week so normally
they'll spend let's be reasonable they
spend about four hours a week on this
type of stuff
Um, there are hourly costs.
So let's say they get paid twenty four
dollars an hour automation potential.
So let's say we're going to automate
eighty percent of this.
So there might be some human involvement,
but we'll say eighty percent.
This is something we're going to automate.
What is down here?
What is this one time implementation?
I think this is like your budget.
Let's say I want to spend... Yeah,
this is all...
It's basically saying exactly like, hey,
this is how much it's going to cost
to do all these processes, right?
Is that what...
So this is saying what's your ROI?
So basically...
And the cool thing is that at least
I understand business,
so I understand the concept behind the
calculator that it just built.
So you're looking at...
The amount of hours that XYZ person spends
on this task and then their hourly cost
is twenty four dollars an hour.
But then you look at the one time
implementation,
like the actual cost of the project.
Let's say I go out and this guy
charged me fifty five hundred dollars,
but he's also going to charge me three
hundred dollars a month to support this
implementation.
What it's saying here is that.
you're still at a net benefit.
You're still in a positive ROI.
Even if you're spending this amount of
money,
you're still going to get some money back
because you're not paying these folks X,
Y, Z dollars.
I'm so sorry.
I got excited because this could be...
I could use this for my advisory stuff.
I'm so serious.
Oh, man.
We just built that.
All right, writing it down.
That's easy, man.
Come on, man.
You got the deal analyzer, dude.
You have the best thing on the market.
Nobody else has that.
I mean, seriously, I think about it.
Nobody else has it.
They got these little mortgage
calculators.
That's cool, but, man,
you got a whole deal analyzer to tell
you, like, hey...
I'm going to plug the numbers in.
This is a good deal.
I have to repair value.
Like, come on, man.
Oh, no, no.
It's legendary.
I'm about to throw it in the chat
so people can understand.
Indeed.
So let's get to the fun stuff, man.
So that was just like showing live the
whole work function.
So again, that's the work function.
You go to new chat.
This is like a brand new feature from
ChatGPT.
And up here at the top,
you just click the work tab,
and then you can actually build out your
stuff.
All right.
So it says I can work on anything.
Summarize my to-dos, draft up.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Emails, okay.
Yeah, man,
remember we talked about the whole
scheduling thing?
Like, that really –
That works.
It actually works.
Yeah, man.
Yeah.
I'm guilty because like it pops up on
my phone.
I'm like, oh my gosh,
I get so excited.
So now I just got to integrate it
into my go high level stuff.
Check this out.
I get a tech brief every single day.
This was today's tech brief.
I just talking about what's going on AI.
Ooh, I like that.
Every single morning I get it, man.
So this was today's the sixteenth.
I had one for the fifteenth every morning,
bro.
So cool.
I can actually,
I can have the email to me if
I want.
You can do,
you can do tons of stuff.
So maybe I could, okay.
I could ask people to join my newsletter.
Yeah.
Sure.
And that's just a tech brief.
Okay.
Yep.
Let me, let me change my, um,
my sharing real quick.
What was your prompt for something like
that?
I think I was using...
It might have been like a thing where
I was... They already had a prompt,
like a news brief,
and I just modified it.
I could tell you.
Just give me one sec.
Well, thank you.
That's a nice newsletter.
That's a cool... Thanks, thanks.
And that's just like my personal thing.
It's not even something I share.
See, that's what I'm telling them.
You should share it.
That's why I'm giving them, you know,
throwing it out there.
Just share it.
It literally is just like an easy prompt.
And actually, yeah, I can scroll right.
It's the cool thing about ChatGPT.
I can scroll right to the top.
So the original prompt was.
Oh, snap.
My bad.
There we go.
Oh, my bad.
Oh,
you were trying to add it to the
stage.
You're good.
Yeah.
All right.
So the original prompt was send me a
daily brief about topics I care about.
And then of course, and then said,
before I said stuff like,
what are the topics you care about as
AI automation,
business software as a solution,
entrepreneurship, Microsoft, um,
what kind of stories do you,
should I emphasize?
So actionable opportunities, tools,
products,
and then how should the briefing feel?
Exactly.
Executive summary.
That was it.
After that, it said done.
It's up the step to start next day.
repeated back to me what the focus was,
the format.
And now every morning, nine o'clock,
I'm hit with a daily brief, man.
That's so powerful, though,
I'm telling you.
That is so powerful.
It's like you got your own assistant
that's sending you, you know,
the topics like a president.
I mean, he's Larry Culture,
the president of the game, for real.
You need to follow and tune in,
for sure.
If you guys go into right here,
top scheduled, you can click on that.
Actually, it'll give you ideas.
So here's a couple things I have
scheduled.
I just thought the real estate deal lab
idea is still running.
Like again,
there's no real limit to what you could
do.
I can have it scan my emails.
So I can set that up to connect
to my,
I think it automatically has connectors
into your Gmail.
We can have it scan it, summarize,
action on emails.
Here we go, add source.
Yeah, so you can connect it using this.
Add your Gmail.
It's going to pop up.
It's going to connect.
All that fun stuff.
But yeah,
there's tons of things you could do.
There's plugins.
So let's say there's a specific
application you want to have integrated
into your ChatGPT.
Canva's a popular one.
What's another popular one here?
Like your Dropbox.
A lot of people store files there.
Your Google Drive.
You can have that automatically plugged in
to your ChatGPT.
Man,
there's so much stuff we got to get
into here at Deliriculture,
but we got to stay focused, man.
Yeah, let's go back to building.
Go back to building.
You know how fast we could build websites,
so let's go to green.
So, yeah, she said the Del Crits.
X said, I never really use the connectors,
but I'll have to check it out.
I didn't know there were so many useful
ones.
Definitely a lot of useful ones.
and at the end of the day uh
we're gonna have a tutorial so so you
definitely want to want to stay tuned for
that because i bug him about all this
all the time i'm like explain it to
me like a third grader because i need
it uh so yeah oh wow okay you
remember them days it's like remember them
days yep well yeah it says green that's
what i had here folks okay
It's like when I had hair.
Man, it's awesome stuff.
All right,
so we're building a website for Green
Foods Market.
Let's see.
You guys, there's already...
There's already a site there,
and we got to change that out because
I want it to be more centric on...
Should I drop some pictures?
Yes.
Okay,
so I'm going to send you some pictures
by email right now.
I still got to visit the shop, man.
I got to do that.
Oh, yeah, man.
Come on down.
And we're really going to revamp it in
a certain kind of way because there's so
much stuff I've done already, right?
And we want to do...
some more.
There's so much to be done.
So let me see here.
and this is uh green foods market really
like a huge labor of love for my
folks who are just amazing people um very
humble people and they do a lot in
the community so i sent you i sent
you some pictures just now let me see
it you know kind of want to let
me see here
Got to add my dad in there.
I didn't get him in the photo shoot.
I got him a photo shoot after,
but it wasn't like that.
Yeah.
You hear music and on your side I
Heard it earlier.
I don't hear it.
No I
Let's start playing it again.
I just wasn't sure it was coming through.
Again,
if you want to listen to the vibes,
they're a culture radio stream,
lo-fi for us bias and for seven.
I mean, I could play it.
I could play it on my side.
That's easy.
I love that.
I'm so serious,
but then it might be too loud.
I don't know.
No, it's all good.
All right,
I'm going to play it on my side.
All right.
All right, I see a picture.
Second set of pictures came through.
You got more pictures.
Hold on, hold on.
Hold on.
We got a plethora to choose from.
Okay, hold on.
Go, go, go.
Let's see.
Could you hear it on your side right
now?
No, I can't hear it.
All right.
no it's it's like coming across real
staticky oh there was just a train go
by all right so
real quick this is what we'll do so
we'll add this and of course this goes
all back down to like the prompts right
right so i'm gonna keep it real simple
and i'm going to go back chat gpt
you chat you turn it off because it's
it's like
All right.
I got, let's see.
And then I have some other ones,
but yeah.
So you throw it back into chat GPT,
right?
And putting in a prompt.
Yeah, so the process,
and this is the best process I've seen
when it comes to building websites,
is focusing first on your brand voice and
image, right?
So your brand is always unique.
You don't want like to determine your
brand because then you get that AI slot
that looks like everybody's stuff looks
the same.
someone to find your brand within ChatGPT
and have it kind of mock it up
or give you like a sample or a
roadmap or a blueprint to work from.
So I'm just going to say here I'm
building a website for people to market.
Market.
Like YouTube.
All right.
This time I'll just say four different.
I think the maximum amount of images you
can do at one time is like ten.
Of course,
it won't take longer for us to get
that ten images.
What I've noticed is I would say three
and four is the sweet spot.
If you ask for more than that many
variations,
you're not going to really get much value
out of it.
they're going to kind of look the same.
So if you say three or four,
you will get some kind of different
looking styles that you can really pick
from.
So four different examples.
Or I would say mock-up. ...
I'm like thinking and type at the same
time.
That's what I like to type.
A lot of people actually do like voice,
but I can't like, I can't talk.
I feel like I can't talk it out.
I can like think about it and type
it out.
That's just the way my brain works at
least.
All right.
I do a little bit of both.
If I'm in a rush,
just talk to it.
I'm saying this because I'm like,
I don't want it to be like, hey,
oh, here's a site you already have.
Let me just recreate it.
No, this is a very outdated site.
Which one?
The square space site.
Oh, yeah, that's definitely out there.
So I'm just going to be like, hey.
I did that.
That was before all of these wonderful
things were happening.
That was done in two thousand fifteen.
Think somewhere around there.
Wow.
It's a Facebook.
I was going to take that as I
take.
A Facebook and then we're going to dump
images here.
And what I like to do is I
like to have a project folder.
This is actually not a light,
but it's very, it's super important.
Here's like all my projects I'm working on
currently.
Yeah.
And I have to bring it to market
right here.
So that's where we'll keep it like
organized then.
Yes,
and when you go to actually build it
with code,
it's super important to keep all that
organized in its own folder because it
actually creates the application and files
within that folder to be able to run
it.
Here we go.
I believe there's going to be a lot
of green.
It's going to pick up on...
Here we go.
Run it.
So it's going to analyze the images.
It's going to look at the Facebook.
It's going to look at the current site.
And it's going to create some website
mock-ups with the knowledge that we have
of Green Foods Market.
And then if you're like,
let's say you don't have an established
business like Green Foods Market,
let's say you're doing a startup,
it's still important for you to think
those things through.
You're going to think about, okay,
How do I want my brand to look?
What is my brand about?
A lot of people that don't have websites,
that starts with how you do your flyers.
We talked about two weeks ago,
people were advertising their business
cards.
Like you still have to think through that
process when you're creating a business
card, when you're creating a flyer.
So even if you don't have a full
website,
but you've already got to the point where
you have a business card or a flyer,
use that as your brand, you know,
or modify that to the way you like
it.
And then say, okay, you know,
Davel is my brand.
I could then use that,
easily transform that to a website.
So here we go, man.
This is actually going a little bit fast.
It's already...
thinking about some things as you can see
it already has seems like the strong
positioning around health being a health
food store in the market plant-based
neighborhood market with groceries fruit
trees like is it on point already oh
yeah oh yeah definitely definitely on
point based on the information we gave it
which is just pictures a facebook page an
outdated website
You're going to throw that shade at me,
huh?
All right, I got you.
It was definitely at me.
It's all good, man.
We having fun.
It was embarrassing to see.
I know.
It's like, you did this.
And, you know, some of those pictures,
I had to upload them myself.
Like, I had to, like,
put a white background in the back.
So I had, like, a little cardboard box.
I would have the picture,
the item in the middle.
I had to take that picture.
Then I would have, oh, yeah.
Yep, you've seen it.
You know exactly which one it is, too.
Yeah, I see it.
I know it's this one.
I see it right here.
Oh, yeah.
Those are definitely it.
Uh-huh.
Damn, I grabbed it from the other side.
Yeah, it was something.
Trust me.
Yep.
But I loaded every one of those products.
Wow.
Grabbed them from the other, like that,
like the honey guy.
Wow.
Yeah, you know them, right?
No, I don't.
Yeah, so they're local as well.
They used to come out to our farmers
markets that we used to have over here
every Sunday.
And every other Sunday or something like
that, we had quite a bit.
We had...
like, sixty to seventy events at once.
Like, it was a lot of events.
And I would always tell people, like,
number one,
you're doing this type of work.
Make sure you're visible and make sure you
have that brand,
but also hit that community hard as hell.
And that's what we did.
We went to everybody's events.
I went to everybody's events that were
doing anything.
And then, you know,
they came out and supported us.
And, you know, we had a great time.
Great time.
community yep yep community there you go
wow one man yeah i like it i
like it can i see it i i
i just need to see it in real
time you might have to drop it in
the chat somewhere i don't know wow yeah
yeah yeah
got a shop, you got the plants, herbs,
visit.
Ooh, that's nice.
That's nice.
I want to add consultant, too, because,
like,
a lot of moms used to come in
and try to get some info from our
mom, too.
Yeah.
You know, some stuff like that, and then,
you know, bookings,
and
You know, they're retired,
so they would love to, you know,
get out there and do stuff.
Yeah, community, school thing.
Yeah, we talked about that.
Yeah.
How come I can't see it no more,
man?
You just dropped it away.
I was having a mesmerized moment.
I was still thinking, man.
This is like, just remember,
we asked for four,
so it's going to do four different.
Oh, gotcha, gotcha.
Yeah.
Plant-based pantry.
Ooh, I like that.
Yeah.
That's right.
Now the hits of AI slop up in
that.
This is the method, though, Chris.
This is the method.
So you got to get through the mock-up
within ChatGPT.
I'm telling you,
ChatGPT has the best image generation I've
seen out of all the AI models.
They're so good right now.
They're so good.
I'm going to, I mean,
I'm still over at the shop.
And let me see if I could call
the mama green foods herself so she could
take a look at this.
It's not even over yet, man.
Hey, man.
You know I get excited.
Come on, man.
Oh, man.
Yeah,
this is the step one in the method.
We should get a couple more,
and then we go from here.
We take it into our CLI.
We actually filled out the website.
There we go.
So version one, blah, blah, blah.
Man, come on.
Give me version two, three, four.
So...
And then though, Chris,
that's only on the medium reasoning.
Wow.
Yeah, it was like one very... Oh,
here's the second one.
Here's the second one, man.
Oh, wow.
Wow.
Remember,
we asked for four different options.
It's going to give us four.
Oh, I like that.
Yeah.
That's the cool thing.
It's like very different fonts.
Like, remember now,
a lot of people look at AI stuff
and it's like, oh, man,
I already know it's AI because of the
font and the way it looks.
So that had to come through.
are very different.
So basically you put that prompt in there
and you see the four that you kind
of like,
you maybe edit it and tweak it.
What's the next step?
What happens next?
So the image is just a mock-up for
the actual AI,
your CLI to go off of.
So the next step
is that project photo that we have.
I'll actually download the mock-up image.
So I got Mama Green foods right here.
Hey, Mama Green.
Hi.
We're working on the website.
We're working on the website right now.
Can you show us the other one right
there?
Yeah.
Oh, wow.
I like that one.
That was one of my first ones.
Wow.
I had them do a photo shoot.
So they have their own products.
That's what we were discussing and working
on today.
So yeah,
this is- Those pictures I haven't even
seen yet.
They're in my laptop.
They live in the laptop.
Let me see if it's guiding me more.
I was still working.
So I asked it before.
It's going to generate the other two.
It's still marching away.
I think right now,
this is the top one.
The white background.
I love it.
It's very clean.
Very inviting.
You can see everything.
Very organized.
You got your plant-based pantry.
I love the way they said pantry, though.
I love that.
I like that.
That was clean.
There's a section you can put the story
behind the green foods market.
Yeah.
Plants and herbs right there to shop.
So the plants and herbs can be like,
you know,
there's some informational stuff.
And they can buy it, too,
because what we have is a lot of
dried herbs from the garden right now.
Yeah, so much, man, so much.
Yeah.
our roots.
Even the copy is different too.
It's not like it's the same headers up
top.
It's like market, garden, our roots.
Explore the market, meet the family.
You could always cut and paste some of
them to mix it up.
This is all going to be the first
step.
This is like we're on a whiteboard.
They're throwing stuff.
Exactly.
Here's the next one.
Boom, here's another one.
Oh, wow.
Remember, guys,
we got totally different sites.
Ideas right here.
Three ideas.
Wow.
Already.
It's working on the fourth one.
I really like that picture.
I know you guys are not going with
this one.
I'm like, nope.
It's got like salmon in there.
yeah definitely definitely not gonna work
but i love that background picture the one
right here yeah this one's nice yeah yeah
that's a dope picture this is a close
one i think the white backgrounds and look
yeah i think it works in or no
no you gotta start way before that you're
gonna start the market we started at in
oh seven
but it wasn't Green Foods Market, right?
So my parents had it as the right
arm ministry.
And they had,
because they believe that the health
message is the right arm of the gospel.
That was the whole concept.
Like you cannot be not healthy and believe
in God kind of thing.
You had to be healthy, mind, body,
and soul, so.
They believe that one thousand percent.
And it's, you know,
it's backed by the Bible itself and and
just health in general.
You had to have a good mind anyway.
Exactly.
So.
So, yeah, that's what they were.
True.
Yeah.
This one and definitely the first one.
So it's still it's still working away on
this last one.
And this is kind of the same thing
we did with yours.
Actually,
this is the exact same thing we did
with your site.
We had, like, what,
three different options?
And then we actually took some things from
other options and mixed them in.
So it's kind of like we knew what
we wanted to do, but then we're like,
oh,
we'll take some ideas from this one and
throw it in.
That's kind of how we developed the real
estate deal lab.
I love that hand treatment.
So that's how we came here.
We're like, yeah, like, have this.
You could take some of that and throw
it on there.
I love this top part here.
This is elegant.
Very premium.
Maybe you could take that other picture.
Maybe you could take that picture with her
from there and throw it on there.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's really just a picture, really.
Everything else is spot on.
So I'm already thinking about the prompt.
It would be like,
take the hero image from here.
Right.
Yeah, that would really, really be good.
Oh, here's the fourth one.
All right.
Oh, wow.
This is like a cultural type of,
I feel like I'm going to a jazz
festival as soon as I see it.
Right, right, right.
My mom probably would not love it.
I feel like I'm about to listen to
the blues, like New Orleans or something.
Yeah.
we're jazzing i love how they take like
the picture and everything and like just
incorporates it into this guys like this
is all done by chat dbt blowing me
away i want all the images by the
way because that's amazing yeah like this
is really beautiful oh more than a market
it's a living community i made it i
made it i made a real hard decision
now
How did I choose from all this, Donville?
You just gave me four different premium
sites.
Four is just too much.
Wow.
Insane.
Man.
Wow.
We got some things to think about, man.
All right.
I know we're short on time,
so we're going to
Paul's here.
We're still going to work on this.
So this is something we're going to work
on.
I'm going to send you these images,
Nathaniel.
Yeah.
And definitely I'll send them up in the
email.
Can't you just send the link and we
can work on it together in that way?
Yes, I believe I can.
That's something we found out the other
day.
You can just share.
You can share the thing.
I was so happy.
I was like, man,
I showed Donville something.
I just shared a link.
Right.
Here we go.
That's awesome.
Wow.
Very good stuff.
If you have any questions, folks,
of what just happened or you want to
see more,
definitely follow and subscribe to Larry
Culture.
He's doing amazing things out here.
Super excited for all of the new
developments.
If you want to see more,
if you want him to work on a
project for you,
we're definitely open to that.
We're going to be doing it in the
community as well.
So definitely keep in touch with us as
well.
That's been a good Tech Thursday.
Hey, I stayed awake.
Look at me.
Awake.
All right.
Wide awake.
Yeah, I know.
I got to take this little drive,
but yeah, I'm wide awake.
All good.
We got W Stream in the chat.
Yeah, appreciate that.
Thanks for staying with us.
We're going to sign out.
We'll continue to work on the website.
Of course, next week,
the website will definitely be live by
then, so we can actually walk you through.
There's going to be a lot of cool
features that we'll put up on there.
Oh, yeah.
Thank you, Daniel.
Always a pleasure.
Y'all have a great night.
Stay safe out there.
Build now.
Yes.
Peace.